it's not surprising you know that that
this is what she's doing and you can
understand that in some ways what she
was doing in the 1970s and what she was
doing back then is what would lead to
things like cutting and self-harm in the
modern world because cutting in
self-harm is also a desire to
participate it's a desire to re-engage
the world right to reawaken our
engagement with the world it's just a
just a very deluded and deranged version
which enters into this this
sadomasochistic Paradigm that appears at
the beginning of the Modern Age right
it's like all I can understand the world
to be is either a world of power in
which I you know inflict pain and
violence and and torture or I am the
recipient of violence and pain and
torture and if I can do that to myself
then I am in like in control of the
nihilism that I mean that I'm living in
of the kind of dark uh world that I'm
engaged with
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
hello to all of you welcome to the
symbolic world today we're going to talk
about art I was really surprised to
notice how many people watched my video
on El Greco and Andy Warhol so I thought
we will push it a little further and
we'll look at contemporary artists like
Maria bravic of pizza gate uh Fame and a
few other contemporary artists and we'll
look at how much of Contemporary Art or
some Contemporary Art is yearning for
participation look at how they come
close to it and also how they struggle
to break through and so uh as you notice
a lot of things have been going on in
the symbolic world we have a new website
that you can sign up to there's a new
community a bunch of of gifts even for
people who sign up and as you can see I
have behind me the beautiful Mosaic that
was made by my carving assistant David
and uh was designed by Heather
paulington and so I'm surrounded by
wonderful people really excited to carry
on with symbolic world as we reach new
levels so what we're going to look at is
the question of Contemporary Art and how
it it uh moves into extremes and moves
towards participation but first what I
wanted you to think about is many of the
modern artists were in some ways in the
what I call pendulum a pendulum of the
Incarnation you could call it where on
the one hand the art tends to move up
towards ideal shapes towards idealism
towards you know and it also tends to
move down towards either popular art or
common art or everyday representations
this pendulum happens in many ways
sometimes it's almost contradictory but
nonetheless the pendulum is there and um
and so here we're looking at an artist
named brancusi many of you will know him
and what's interesting about these
artists is that if you look at what
they're doing some of it you know
who has written much about iconography
has even suggested the possibility that
you know there's something akin to icons
in some of the modern movements if you
look at the way the face is simplified
this desire to kind of Define the basic
geometry of the face and to represent it
is something that Aiden sees happening
in icons if you look at the difference
between Roman art and Christian medieval
art or iconographic art you get a sense
that the iconographic art is more
distilled it doesn't tend to show a lot
of the excesses of the material world it
tends to let's say Rectify or simplify
the forms now this wasn't necessarily
done with a the same drive as the modern
artist that is really trying to almost
reduce to an Essence uh but nonetheless
there is something that you might want
to see as Akin now
this is true but it's interesting to
think about how there is a in terms of
moving towards an art of course of
participation you have a basic issue
which is going to be in some ways the
development of the personal style and so
as brancusi or other artists want to do
this distilling they also at the same
time end of creating things that are so
you know particular to themselves that
they you know that their their
personality is impregnated completely on
it and so it doesn't have a kind of
universal appeal communal appeal that
the traditional Arts would have like
images and icons they do distill the
forms but they do that in a way that is
also calling to participation in a
community whereas brancusi is creating
artists of contemplation uh objects of
contemplation objects of aesthetic
pleasure uh that would be in people's
houses or in buildings but don't
necessarily have so much of that
capacity to participate in a community
another example is of course Kandinsky
now many people have pointed Kandinsky
out to me saying you know isn't
Kandinsky something akin to what you're
trying to do right he's trying to find
the meaning and colors Kandinsky created
this whole theory of color symbolism
where each color represented certain
moods certain states of human uh
existence and then he created this
almost symbolic language of colors in
his paintings where he brought all these
colors together you know contrasting
with each other and uh and and existing
together in order to bring about this
kind of symbolic language of color and
so there is something interesting about
that once again in the way that my
friend Aiden Hart uh points out that
there's something of that in color in in
icons where an icon certain colors have
certain uh a certain importance in
certain representations for example we
represent the veil of the Virgin with a
royal color you know we use gold we use
white uh we use dark black and Darkness
to manifest certain characteristics and
so it's not as uh typified as in
Kandinsky and it's not as typified as
sometimes people want to think but there
is definitely a basic symbolism of color
that exists in the icons now once again
the issue with Kandinsky and this of
course happens also with people like
Pete mondria
is a is an artist who's trying to do
something similar he was a theosophist
and so you know a kind of a spiritualist
in the in the early sense that it you
know something akin to what a new Ager
would be today and he tried to create
these simple images of proportions
mathematical proportions and and and
Primal colors in order to create this
kind of spiritual experience of the
painting now
what are the issues with with both of
these is that for example with Kandinsky
you have the problem that his forms and
his colors create a very idiosyncratic
language and so in the desire to
actually create something which would be
Universal devoid of cultural uh you know
cultural hooks that it's not this or
that person it's not this or that scene
it's an it's a universal language what
ends up happening is rather the opposite
is that Kandinsky creates a language
which is completely utosyncratic to
himself and that you know unless you've
read his book on color you would
struggle to find any meaning in his
paintings even in terms of Impressions
The Impressions that his paintings
create on the viewer are not really
exactly what he would think they're
doing with his whole very complex theory
of color now the same happens with p is
that you know although his mathematical
proportions they are Universal they are
very much uh
once again void of the capacity to
participate and so these images you look
at them but what are they what are they
doing what is happening with these
images and what's important to
understand in terms of the pendulum is
to understand how in the early modern
age and this is something which will be
repeated early modernism not Modern Age
to say at the beginning of the 20th
century something which will be repeated
over and over is that you end up having
movements of artists that represent
things that look very similar to each
other but for app completely opposite
reasons this happened especially in
Russia so in Russia you had two
movements you had a movement that you
could call supremacism uh you see this
in malovich of course malovich who is
kind of continuing kandinsky's line of
representing these pure mathematical
forms these pure shapes these pure
colors on on canvases in order to create
a supreme uh you know kind of platonic
experience of the forms in the paintings
um and so there was almost like a
spiritualism which is devoid of body and
you see that of course in multi as well
you know it's trying to create these
pure patterns pure patterns that are
that are are are spiritual but that
don't land that don't
incarnate in in the world the way
patterns actually usually incarnate in
the world right you don't perceive
mathematical proportions you perceive
them you know if you look at the golden
mean for example you know the golden
mean appears as different proportions
the proportions of the body the
proportions of buildings you know that
that are participated in you enter into
the building and the fact that your body
is made of certain proportions connects
with the proportions of the church and
so there might be a little bit of that
in the painting but the painting is
something that you stand in front of and
you look at that weird activity of just
visual uh experience uh is something
which is not integrated with other
aspects of reality so now what's
interesting about Russian supremacism is
that it gives birth to a movement that
is its opposite which is called
constructivism and the constructivists
are also using these geometric shapes
but they're using them in a almost
reductionist manner in a Marxist way so
on the one hand you have this kind of
idealism this this High spiritualism in
the supremacist and now this this landed
very very practical uh use in
constructivism now you look at this and
you would you might think okay so what's
the difference right what's the
difference between this which is
constructivism and this which is
supremacism and that's my point my point
is that you know these extremes manifest
manifest themselves in a very surprising
way where people on the one hand someone
who wants to create idealistic spiritual
forms and the other person who wants to
create Marxist working class you know
reductionist objects that are made of
real things you know that are that are
completely material in there for the
even the reason of their being will end
up making something similar and so for
the same reason what you end up seeing
is the constructivists end up using the
tools of modernism and the the design
tools of simple geometric forms in order
to create propaganda whereas something
like creating propaganda out of a out of
abstract geometric forms is something
that the supremacist like malovich would
have found completely abhorrent and the
total opposite of what it is they're
trying to do now this of course will
continue on into the the uh the Modern
Age and when you get to the 1960s and
70s you have the exact same problem in
the United States and in Europe as well
you end up having two movements one
which is called conceptual art and the
other which is called minimalism and
what happens is you have these two
extremes and so conceptual art uh you
know this this is you know this is
supposed to be very smart so Joseph
kosuth you know he puts a chair in the
gallery and then puts a picture of the
chair and and then puts the definition
of the chair to kind of help you
understand that you know how these
objects are actually ideas and that the
idea is what is more important than the
physical instantiation of the object and
so you know
it's super interesting because this is a
very very uh boring thing it's a very
boring statement and it's also a cold
clinical action that you know is
supposed to create just this reflection
on
on the relationship between different
representations of an idea in the world
and different uh you know putting
putting out there in terms of uh of uh
the creation of an art object right
because this is the problem now this
chair you know is not is not an actual
chair right it's not a it's not a chair
that you sit on it's a fetishized chair
that is used in the gallery in order to
to create a artistic experience I guess
and so although and so again you have
this problem of the alienation which the
art object uh end up creating in the in
the world and so you and then you end up
having all these tropes of trying to
kind of Break Free Break through the
issue that that the gallery space
provides and you know the Art Space
provides uh the most extreme version of
this kind of conceptual art that is
trying to be revolutionary if you
remember my last lecture on uh on El
Greco and in your Warhol is of course
Piero manzoni who did the you can read
it for yourself he created uh cans of
art that contained his own uh excrement
um and we don't even know if they really
did but that was the point the point is
to have these cans that contain the
X-Men of the artist and put them in the
gallery who's kind of taking dushan's
gesture to an extreme uh but manzoni did
all kinds of things like that where he
would he would take a vial of glass and
fill it with air in Paris you know just
have a vial of glass open in pairs close
it and then show it all over the world
and call it you know air from Paris or
something uh it was this desire to to
kind of expose in some ways it's almost
the very mechanisms of Art and the Very
mechanisms of how of how art is a a a
fetishized representation of something
that has lost its purpose so it's not
clear exactly what his point was in the
sense that is he denouncing it is he
participating it maybe he's doing both
at the same time you know but he can
perceive the problem of participation
and the problem of the space the Art
Space itself as this strange space where
we put put things there in order for us
to just look at them and they don't have
a kind of integration into into the the
world and so this conceptual artist this
can high high conceptual art well at the
same time exist with other artists that
are doing what we call minimalist art
and here we're looking at pure
reductionism so if you look at an
abstract painting by uh Frank Stella for
example and so you know abstract lines
on a on a canvas and it might make you
think that this has more to do with
Mount itch but someone like Frank Stella
would be the very opposite of malovich
he would say that my paintings are just
paint on a Surface that's all they are
they have no meaning they have nothing
except for just being paint on a Surface
now obviously you know at this point
hopefully everybody can understand that
this is a of course a ridiculous gesture
it's a ridiculous yes you're to think
that you can have just paint on a canvas
the whole question of relevance and and
and and of wondering why I would care
about paint on a canvas and not care
about paint on a wall or not care about
you know whatever it is is of course
re-engaging and is a kind of strange uh
almost blind spot of an artist like
Frank Stella where you know the the
putting in the gallery of this canvas
with abstract painted lines on it
cannot avoid entering into the whole
question of meaning of prestige and of
relevance and a question of culture and
why we would have these objects that we
Elevate above other objects and that we
see as being kind of uh fetishized as
culture as culture objects rather than
just everyday common day objects and so
you know you can see how the pendulum
calls it's each other right the pendulum
just just calls one extreme to the other
and sometimes even in the same object
and so without the whole uh
structure of art the whole structure of
of culture and this whole idea of these
objects of contemplation and and that
are fetishized and put above common day
objects almost in a religious way Frank
Stella could not be making his paintings
and so even though he makes it
reductionist move the very fact that we
care about his reductionist move you
know makes his art participate in The
Other Extreme all the time and you see
the same thing with any of the
minimalist artists uh here more examples
Carl Andre Donald Judd who created these
simple materials they would just create
these forms uh and you know the Donald
judge boxes are made out of plywood
they're made out of very common
materials and put up in galleys in a
very simple way uh in a very
reductionist gesture
once again you know there is very
difficult for them to avoid this
pendulum now
one of the things that happened and it's
interesting to start thinking about is
that there is in the 1960s especially
and it's then in the 1970s you have
almost like a breakout where I think
many of the artists starting to realize
just how sterile a lot of this abstract
art would be coming this conceptual art
these minimalists are how sterile and
and just uh because they fetishized in
the weirdest way that these objects
started to be coming and so what you
have is artists that almost tried to
start to break out and uh in that group
you have
um performance artists who start to use
art almost in a ritual fashion this is
what I mean by the the question of
ritualization so this is Joseph Boyce uh
Joseph Boyce was a airplane pilot in
World War II and his plane crashed and
he has a whole story about what happened
to him and so his art tends to deal with
these issues right with the issues of
the of the war the issues of survival
the issues of the human person put in
contact with animality
um
and so some of it is a little simplistic
because it's almost like his own uh
process of healing through what he went
you know like the felt blanket that he
would have had in the military the sled
a flashlight you know there's a sense in
which he's creating these spaces that
are that are just putting things
together in a way that is
let's say remembering participation
right so it's the object in the gallery
is obviously just fetishized like all
the other art objects but because he's
trying to
bring about a memory of the war a memory
of you know how these objects
participated in his own life then
there's something going on now we're
going to get back to Joseph's boys but
first the most famous of the uh
performance artists especially right now
is of course Marina Abramovich and uh
and it's interesting to think about her
and her work in which she was trying to
do because
in some ways you know she was also
trying to kind of break through the
problem of art art especially you know
represented as here's the art and here's
the public and now we go in and we are
these passive
these passive almost uh you know
consumers and we just look at these art
objects and there's no form of
connection to the world and to life and
so what she was trying to do you know
she was trying to do a lot of things but
one of the things she seems to be trying
to do is to try to break to break
through that that problem so she did
very strange performances or one of her
most famous performance is uh is shown
here where Marina uh around which stood
in a gallery for six hours and she put
on a table a bunch of objects and all
those objects were objects that a
certain amount of people in the space
with her were allowed to use on her and
so you had feathers you had paper string
you could kind of see but you also had
more dangerous objects like a gun Like a
Knife
um and she just stood there for six
hours she wasn't allowed to react but
she just had to take it and then
everybody in the gallery was allowed to
do whatever they want they were absolved
of any responsibility legally of course
probably some of this is quite staged
you know I don't want to question her
method
um but of course as you can imagine the
situation starts very likely and then
accelerates and it ends in moments where
you know she's very much in Danger
wearing a knight is used on her uh you
know there's a she's stripped she's put
on the table you know all these things
that are happening to her you know
someone's you know kind of threatens her
with a knife and so in the end someone
tries pulls the gun out and then someone
reaches me God takes the gun away uh and
so you know it's like intensity a nice
Hollywood movie
um but what what it seems like she's
trying to do is
trying to break through the problem of
of this passive relationship to the art
object now she's doing it obviously in a
very modern way she's doing it in a way
which tends to reduce human
no she now becomes the passive and the
viewer becomes active and the whole
relationship is one which seems to be
framed on the possibility of sadism and
a kind of passive masochism and so of
course the the the the relationship that
she brings about is a very tortuous
modern relationship but she's trying to
bring back you could say something like
the stakes like the stakes of art like
what are we doing imagine a in the
ancient world where you build a church
and people would go and worship and
there would be these rallots would be
taken into the church and people would
light candles you know uh and then uh
people would
people when they were angry at uh at the
king or whatever they would deface the
statue and there was this whole
relationship of of art which was seen as
participative and connected to to life
and so it seemed like she is trying to
re-engage that in a very uh perverse way
but nonetheless you can see that there's
a sense that there's despair in the art
world that that we realize that this is
a problem what are what are these
paintings like what is you know there's
nothing wrong with decorating decorative
art but is that what it is is that all
these paintings uh are are I don't most
of the modern artists don't think so
they think they're doing something
extremely important but in the end these
art objects end up just being passive uh
objects to look at you know to trade to
exchange to to make money off of
and so artists like her try to break
that with this type of activity and so
she's famously known for doing all kinds
of weird things you know here's a
performance where she holding a bow and
her friend is pulling on the arrow and
for six minutes he just holds the arrow
stretched out and if he would let go she
would die of course the arrow would go
into her heart
um and so it's all about again the same
weird problem of how to represent a kind
of
uh uh you know and this is not just
entertainment right this is not just a
performance in the sense of uh of the
play right or the ballet or something
that is without stake that it's just
people doing things and we watch it and
we go home there's a sense in which
she's putting yourself in danger while
she is creating this this performance uh
of course you know as like I said before
the relationship seems to be reduced to
a kind of state of masochism uh and
which is very close you know it's funny
people don't realize to what extent uh
masochism is related to modernism and to
what extent in the enlightenment at the
birth of the Enlightenment appears both
characters right
the two Originators of what we could
call sadism and masochism because there
is already a problem once the
Enlightenment and its pendulum starts to
swing you can see the the first fruits
of that in this reduction of
relationships on the idea of acting
purely on someone right being the
complete actor where the other person is
a complete passive uh puppet for your
desires and on the on the other hand the
opposite of becoming that pure puppet
for someone else's desires of just
becoming a passive recipient of other
people's desires and violence that that
is something which would inevitably
happen at the birth of modernism and so
Marina whether she knows it or not is
putting on the scene this relationship
this kind of weird sadomasochist
relationship that the modern world has
in a desire to re-engage re-engage the
stakes of Art and re-engage I think it
kind of participation at least at least
the stakes you know of Art and so much
of her art is is and so she became very
famous because she's ditched and weird
and stuff now this is one of her
performances where she just sits in a
galley space with a bunch of cow bones
and she spends six hours a day or eight
hours a day whatever trying to wash the
blood from the bones that's all she did
she would sit in the gallery and she
would just try to wash the blood off the
bones for hours that he creates again
it's very dark image of what it is to be
human what it is to participate you know
is that is that what human life is right
is that what human life is to try to
wash the blood off of Bones right
the imagery is quite Stark and it is
quite uh you know it's actually a very
good image of what contemporary life is
and what the Contemporary world is this
is what the world of participation in
the modern world the analogy or the
metaphor for for participation is now
she got herself in in a lot of trouble
in the last few years because she did a
lot of weirdest stuff things that are
closer to the occult things that are
closer to rituals now you can understand
whether she's sincere or not like
whether or not she's doing it on purpose
or not how what she's doing is coming
closer to resembling rituals because
intuitively we understand that
ritualization is a form of participation
which is closer to the way that we
understand art what art is that is it's
a reduction of the world the compression
of the world into into a kind of dance a
kind of ordered gesture uh ordered
object making uh
reductive object we compress things into
images we compress you know the cup that
is used in the Liturgy is it kind of
compressed cups like it's a couple of
Cups right it's a ritualized cup it's
not just the cup you use every day but
it is but it is a a condensation of cup
so there's a there's a inevitable almost
sense that what will happen is is as
there's this desire to break out of the
of the just the passive relationship to
Art things that people are doing these
performance artists will often start to
look like ritual now whether they
themselves conceive what they're doing
as rituals nonetheless it's
participating in the same Aesthetics and
there's there's no surprise that the
rituals that they will engage with will
be rituals which will reflect the
sickness of the modern world you know
and so she got of course also into a lot
of trouble with with these these
performances she did where they were
that were Spirit cooking or whatever you
know she's done a lot of things she
would write up all these absurd recipes
that look like magical formulas using
human fluids and stuff mixed together in
order to create uh food
and she did she does a lot of things
with pain where she would film herself
just you know putting her hand over a
candle or whatever and just burning
herself
you know I mean it's it's not surprising
you know that that this is what what
she's doing and you can understand that
in some ways what she was doing in the
1970s and which she was doing uh back
then is what would lead to things like
cutting and self-harm in the modern
world because cutting in self-harm is is
also a desire of to participate it's a
desire to re-engage the world right to
reawaken uh our our engagement with the
world it's just a just a very deluded
and deranged version which enters into
this this sadomasochist the Paradigm
that appears at the beginning of the
Modern Age right it's like all I can
understand the world to be is either a
world of power in which I you know
inflict pain and violence and and
torture or I am the recipient of
violence and pain and torture and if I
can do that to myself then I am in like
in control of the nihilism that I mean
that I'm living in right of the of the
kind of dark uh world that I'm engaged
with
um so you can kind of understand why
this is happening it doesn't reduce from
how dark it is but of course the the
most important um to me the most
important thing that Marina did recently
that kind of shows us an image of of the
modern world and what is going on is the
event she did at the at the Museum uh of
Modern Art in La I think that's where it
is and so she did this performance with
the singer Blondie of all people where
you know now we had a full-on scale
desire to re-engage participation and so
she did a created and an art event which
was also eating you know and so remember
all the things that I've said about that
you know eating as an active
participation and communion especially
as the kind of highest ritual Act and
the highest active participation but
that is a form of ritualized eating
because eating is so close to our you
know our engagement with the world and
so now what she does is she creates a a
feast of eating and I'm not going to
show you uh all the pictures because
they're quite disturbing uh you know
where she engages all the tropes of
cannibalism
you know and all the tropes of uh of
human sacrifice into her event so she
had these cakes made of herself and of
the Blondie singer and the cakes came in
on these tables and now with a knife
they stabbed them and cut them and cut
pieces and handed pieces of their of
their cake to the people and you can see
how it's a parody of course obviously of
communion a parody of of uh the Lord's
Supper but done in a kind of uh dark
carnivalesque way but that is
nonetheless right trying to like in
their own perverted disturbing way
trying to re break through the problem
of the passivity of the art of the art
object the passivity of of the of the
entertainment culture and of
representation culture and so during the
event on the tables they had actors
artists who just stuck their head
through the table and their their heads
were like the centerpiece almost like in
like a pig with it in his mouth in the
middle of the table as people were
eating they were just sit there and
stare blankly and they had you know
naked women lying on tables with like
skeletons on them and you know just very
dark and disturbing things right
and so close to ritualization that of
course you know during the night to 2016
kind of uh frenetic thing around
pizzagate uh people started seeing these
images and freaking out and the thing is
with good reason you know it's so funny
that someone like her engages with
tropes of occult cannibalism all these
very very dark images and then defends
herself and says you know oh I'm just an
artist this is just art but her whole
project is about breaking through the
just art like breaking through the idea
that artists are just like innocent
people who represent things that she's
trying to break through she's trying to
re-engage she's trying to use images of
her own self-harm and her own uh you
know doing all these these very dark uh
disturbing gestures and then she's
surprised when it breaks out and then
people react in a way that links it to
the very things that she's using as her
Source material in her order to create
these things and so whether an action is
an actual Satanist or an occultist like
I've said off often in these videos it's
like I don't have access to that and to
be honest I don't care but the the the
the the truth that she's using are those
if you use tropes of cannibalism and you
use tropes of human sacrifice and you
you use tropes that are that are that
are magical spells and magical formulas
in your recipes and whatever then don't
be surprised if people react to that as
if that's what you're doing
it's just funny to see how she she that
then she tried to play the victim and
you can see there's all these articles
you can find them online where she's
playing the victims like oh stop
harassing me I'm just an artist you know
uh all these conspiracy theorists that
are saying that I'm doing these dark
things well you are doing these dark
things uh you might not take it
seriously maybe you're just doing it you
know to be an artist whatever that means
but the like I said the tropes you're
engaging uh those are the tropes those
are the tropes so you know
obviously I don't want people to harass
her or whatever I wouldn't want I don't
want that to happen but you know
nonetheless this is what is this is what
is going on in your work now one of the
things I want to do is return to Joseph
Boyce uh because
Joseph boys you know
understood what he was doing very much
as ritual and and he was almost using
kind of shamanistic uh shamanistic thing
he did these performances where he would
lock himself in in a room with uh with
like Wool with a wolf and he wore this
felt blanket and would like engage with
uh with the wolf in certain ways uh and
was trying to almost create these
rituals and one of the problems that
where they were trying to deal with
these artists was of course World War II
and you know Joseph Boyce was a German
artist how to deal with the scandal of
World War II how to break through the
guilt and the shame and the the guilt
you know the all the things that
happened that he did as a soldier that
Germans did uh and so trying to create
these almost rituals of atonement in
order to get through that and so he did
all kinds of stuff uh you know uh kind
of absurdist things now of course the
problem with this is is the same problem
as with Kandinsky is that you can
totally understand the desire to
re-engage rituality you can totally
understand the the desire to also feel
like there's no way to atone for the
sins of your people for your own sins
and try to create rituals of atonement
and of transformation about but
when you do it in a gallery and you do
it you know in a space that is just
there to to hold art objects when you do
it in a language that becomes so
idiosyncratic that nobody can
participate it except for you that
people are looking at you ripping up
pieces of paper and you know writing on
billboards and skinning a hair like you
did all kinds of stuff uh you know
playing the piano absurdly uh that you
you might think that you're kind of
doing something that's breaking through
but ultimately this will remain with you
right it it will not become a true
language of a participation another
artist that I personally enjoy and like
I said it's just because each of these
artists has a little hint that there's a
desire to move away from a kind of
finishization and and and of the of Art
and a you know and the kind of
meaningless not meaninglessness but you
know this idea of Art For Art's Sake
that this pure art that just exists uh
is is an artist called and some Kiefer
so Ansel Kiefer did things that were
similar to what Joseph Boyce was doing
um and but his whole uh let's say theme
is about the possibility of using art as
a a kind of medicine where the
representation of the images could take
let's say culture and break it down or
bring it down uh into the dark place and
then try to have it rise back up and so
you know he would represent some of
these Nazi uh Nazi building there's not
the architecture and would cover it with
tar would would try would cover it with
like all with uh actual material not
just paint you know he would he would
have Ash and he would put sand and and
straw and all these things on the
paintings and would you know and and
trying to in some ways you know
re-baptize or
or refound these buildings that are
there right what do you do now you have
these Nazi buildings that are there in
Berlin or in other places in Germany and
how do you get through this like do you
destroy them do you do you just get rid
of them and so his sense is that there's
a kind of deep duplicity in his art
where he he is trying in some ways to
recast uh very uh with a hesitation
these objects and almost trying to act
like a kind of traditional healer and
heal these art objects now once you
understand that what he's doing his art
the key to his art opens up very simply
he represents you know these lead wings
or sometimes you represent a lead artist
uh palette painter's palette that will
be stuck on top of his of his uh images
he represent airplanes sometimes War
airplanes as this dual symbol of
something which is both dark but Also
Rises up and so there's this ambiguity
about his work and but the ambiguity
seemed to be wanting to kind of push
through and to to to to break through
the problem of modernism and the problem
of World War II
um
the iconology that he uses is actually
quite uh it's a little simplistic you
know it's a little it's a little over
the top so here's a simple example right
he a man lying on his back and then out
of him is coming this thing a flower uh
uh you know a kind of stream and this is
going up now becoming a flower that dies
and the seeds now fall back on the earth
and so you can kind of see this cycle of
death and rebirth that he's trying to
show in the image here this is actually
the Louvre
um you can see that there's a bunch of
books right and the books are kind of
stacked and and piled and they they're
made of lead and so they're dead you
know in some ways they're kind of like
the problem of uh you know I talk about
this the problem of culture and the
problem of uh the problem of uh of art
as this supplement as this kind of dark
aspect to culture in general and so he
gets that
um and then he shows out of it you know
a nonetheless kind of letting fly hours
so if you had seen this in person the
very center of these dead flower is
gilded it has gold on it and then a few
of the seeds that have fallen back onto
the trees onto the books are also golden
and so a lot of it is lead and if you
have this kind of little hope piercing
through right this dead this dead
culture see the same uh you know in this
image as well so the sunflower comes up
and then the sunflower drops its seeds
back onto the ground and you hope that
some of it will be reborn the sunflower
seeds are also stars in his kind of
imagination you can understand you know
here is something like the Milky Way uh
this idea of like the principalities
coming up and then acting back upon us
you know so there's something about his
work which is obviously a little kitschy
a little new agey a little simplistic
and it's uh in its kind of basic um
imagery something that you might find in
a kind of second-rate Union type of
thing but the desire to represent this
this kind of decadence and this
breakdown of culture and the weight of
history and how you know in this death
that there might be something that is
reborn I think is a desire and a hope
that for sure I share and and so I do
find some resonance in in his work in
that sense and I think that
understanding that is something that has
pushed me towards some of the things
that I'm doing now the problem of course
with keeper and just like the problem
with Joseph Boyce or the problem with uh
Marina bromovic is that the spaces in
which they create these things they are
artificial spaces themselves right the
museum the gallery the these are are
kind of fetishized spaces they aren't
spaces of they aren't the Public Square
they aren't the church they aren't the
the Civic buildings they aren't the
things that we kind of recognize as
holding our identity holding our
participation
um and and although the artist you know
created these Gallery spaces not the
artists but first the art dealers
created these spaces just for art in
order to sell art and those those spaces
became uh you know like just places to
see art and to to to visualize it
um
is the desire to break through now
I don't think they succeed I don't think
they succeed because they're trapped
inside the art world they're trapped
inside a weird like keeper for example
his his paintings are very much on the
Art Market they're they're objects of
speculation for for our dealers and art
collectors you know uh and so just like
all the other artists he probably
manages how many pieces he puts out in
the market you know calculates his moves
in order to make sure to make the the
best killing in terms of selling all of
these things are inevitable in the in
the art World
um and then collectors will uh let's say
want to see shows by this artist in
order to make their collection be worth
more so there's this strange uh this
whole strange things in which they
participate and the same thing with
Marina Abramovich you know she's she she
has these this this Art Foundation and
then she has it funded by these Elites
in order to make performance art that
exists only within the space of the art
is the space of art uh and doesn't
really
land right it doesn't it doesn't turn
into folk dances it doesn't turn in to
things that people imitate uh and in
some way she probably doesn't even want
that to happen because she she doesn't
totally understand the way that patterns
embody themselves in the world
and so but what you can see is at least
the desire to kind of break through and
I think that once you see that you can
understand why you know there are ways
to do it you know that there's a uh a
possibility of re-engaging and you know
at least in my vision it starts with
liturgical art because the liturgical
space the church is still a true space
of participation it is not although in
some Churches in Europe it has become a
fetishized museum most churches at least
are still and sometimes the ones that
are the least beautiful or that aren't
as beautiful as the great Cathedrals for
example are our spaces of true
participation and so the possibility of
creating objects within that
that world you know can anchor them in
terms of their beauty but then also in
terms of the participation now in order
to give you a bit of hope it's not like
these Contemporary Art movements were
the only movements to exist in the
modern world there were movements that
try to also integrate the different
forms so there are art movements that
try to you know resist this
fetishization that happened in the in
the modern world you know uh you can see
that of course in in movements like uh
the arts and craft movements and also
our Nouveau which try to link you know
the
the architectural the object print
making that tried to kind of integrate
that into the into the world now
I think that the arts and craft movement
and our Nouveau succeeded much more than
the modern artists in avoiding the
extremes now of course one of the issues
with with the arts and craft movement
and our Nouveau is there was nonetheless
this kind of um how can I say this there
was a a lack of of anchoring a little
bit in terms of form you know there was
a Fantastical movement especially our
Nouveau where we kind of moved over
these Fantastical shapes that moved into
extremes and it were very hard to
embody in the long term for example so
it's not surprising that our Nouveau was
like a flash that really tried to
integrate but then didn't really succeed
in the end and ended up kind of falling
apart and also because they there was so
much emphasis on ornament you know you
see that with William Morris and the and
some of the arts and craft people there
was so much beautiful ornamentation you
can see that you know in the uh you can
see that in these Interiors for example
where there's a there's a rich use of
fabric I want a mutation trying to kind
of integrate these things into the
common life Beauty into the common world
so not just Beauty for beauty sake but
but Beauty in a chair Beauty in a beauty
in a in a curtain in something that is
part of the everyday life
um and so you know there's still some of
that people can still kind of hold on to
that a little bit but uh there was such
a there was such a kind of access you
could say in the in the Aesthetics in
terms of I mean here it's like gilded
peacocks on the wall you know this type
of gilded surfaces and extremely uh you
know designed surfaces are things that
maybe should be reserved for civic
spaces for
um
for churches but of course because Art
Nouveau was a modern movement it got
focused on homes and you know it's okay
for your home to be beautiful but if you
push it too much and you create these
excessively lavish homes that aren't for
a king for example that are that are
trying to be a model for the way in
which we exist it's going to be
difficult to kind of hold on to that but
there are some things from these
movements that we can nonetheless
capture and a kind of vision in order to
think differently about how art
participates in life and to understand
that you know the possibility of
integrating Beauty into the everyday
into the everyday object is something
which is not uh is not impossible
because the the Arts and Crafts movement
and the art removal movement was able to
make beautiful lands beautiful pots
beautiful you know different objects of
just participation uh in the world and
so there is a bit of access and so you
can understand why you know the
modernist tend to think that because of
industrial
um the industrial process that these
types of ornamentation have become
impossible that we should really you
know move towards uh you know a kind of
uh simple simple simple uh geometric
forms so hopefully this was just a bit
of fun for you to kind of understand and
see that the not only does the modern
world and modern art really emphasize
these extremes often this pendulum of
abstraction you know high high
attraction but then also materialist
varying reductionist concerns but that
there were desires and there's artists
that tried to break
through you know this just passive weird
uh art object tried to re-engage
participation but would often do it in a
way that would nonetheless re-engage
these extremes extremes of idiosyncrasy
extremes of of uh of sadism and
masochism into terms in the case of
Abramovich
um you know and and create these obscure
languages that nobody understood
although there are some like and some
keeper that I show you who were
re-engaging images that you could
recognize right the wing uh artists
palette a human body these things trying
to be reintegrated a little kitschy
maybe a little new agey uh but but at
least you can perceive the desire right
this desire to break through and uh
ultimately I do think that uh that
liturgical art is the way out at least
for you know not to become a famous
artist and to become a and to become
known and to be shown in magazines or
whatever and in in different uh
Publications but but in order to really
participate in in a community Beauty
making meaning making within the
community uh this seems to be at least
the anchor of a way outfit so thanks
everybody for your attention I hope you
enjoyed it
um and uh I will talk to you very soon